so as you know if you follow this
channel i am something of a connoisseur
of
tick-tock videos we all have our hobbies
this is mine i don't enjoy them i study
them
much like an anthropologist or some
other kind of scientist i put on my lab
coat
and i and i analyze these videos it's
all for the sake of science is what i'm
trying to say
so last week we took a look at uh
feminist tiktok videos and this week
we're gonna study and analyze a
different
sub-genre um here we have parenting
tick-tock these are tick-tockers who've
made videos
giving their parenting wisdom maybe we
can learn something
you know i've got four kids but there's
always there's always more to be learned
so i'm not gonna be uh
egotistical about this i'll try to be
humble and i will humble myself
before the tick tockers and see if they
have anything of value to tell me so
we'll start um
with this video here my kids are allowed
to tell me no
they have a voice and i want to hear it
i want them to make decisions
so they are allowed to say no but there
are rules guidelines
i don't know there's more to it most
importantly you have to be polite
if they've politely declined they better
be ready to explain themselves complete
their case i always encourage
conversation we're developing critical
thinking skills and communication
say i asked my daughter to clean her
room and she says no thanks i don't
really want to right now
she's not getting in trouble for that i
mean i get it i look at messes i have to
clean all the time and think
i don't feel like it i have quick
conversations i remind her that she
can't earn her privileges until her
responsibilities are complete she'll
remind me that she already knows that
and then she'll tell me her plan and
when she plans to get things done
usually she follows through sometimes
she needs reminding i always want my
kids to feel safe and comfortable saying
no
and that starts with me i respect my
kids in the same way i want them to
respect
me i don't think you can earn respect by
demanding obedience
you earn respect by earning trust
okay first of all why every video on
tick tock is a woman doing her makeup
while she
talks to you or someone pointing to
words on a screen rather than just
saying it america explains
i don't understand that also you told
your daughter to clean her room and she
said
no i don't feel like she politely
declined
hey go clean your room oh uh no mother i
will decline
nah i don't really feel like it i will
decline your invitation to clean my room
well okay then how's that an option you
accept
me when i tell my kids to do something
and they say no i say oh no you see
you didn't understand no is not an
option oh no you didn't
you forgot you're talking to dad right
this is dad you're talking to
there's no no here no isn't in your
vocabulary right now i wasn't i wasn't
asking for you oh you thought i wanted
your opinion
no no no no uh this is not a democratic
deliberation i'm telling you to do it so
do it this isn't a democracy anymore
end of discussion now we do have a
follow-up from this same woman
about that video we just watched and
she's doing her makeup again of course
uh let's watch that
while ago i made a video about how i let
my kids say no and manage their own time
that video got
really mixed reviews some people loved
the idea and some people thought it was
horrible
but that's all right i don't expect
everyone to agree with me i'm not trying
to tell anyone how to parent i'm just
sharing what works for us
however i got a comment yesterday i want
to talk about i'm not gonna video reply
to the comments i noticed if i do that
to a comment that disagrees with me
people go back and be mean to that
commenter and i don't like that that's
not what we're doing here so the
comments said you're gonna regret
letting them say no you think you're
being fair but all you're doing is
teaching your kids that they're your
equals and they're not
a friend i think that's where we
disagree because i do believe my kids
are my equals the way i see it is that
my kids didn't decide to be here
i decided to have children and with the
decision i made i have the
responsibility to build up their
self-worth and make sure they understand
they are equal and not just to me but to
every human
i gave my kids life and they don't owe
me anything for it
i owe them a good life this lady is
either the nicest person on earth
or a serial killer and there is no in
between now i can imagine her
i could go the way i i could imagine her
holding the door
open and saying good morning i could
also imagine her you know
tying me down to a slab and dismembering
me like i you i could you sort of
imagine either one of those things
maybe it shows how not nice i am it
shows what a miserable bastard that i am
that if you're nice i accuse you of
being a serial killer so this might
really be more about me than her i'll
admit
niceness is so foreign to me that when
somebody is nice
i'm like hey what's your angle here what
are you doing what are you doing right
now what is this
anyway nice or not this again is totally
wrong yes kids kids are equal
in the sense of their human worth and
dignity
so that's when we talk about human
equality in general that's what we mean
uh moral worth all humans are equal in
that way but they're not equal in any
other sense
they're not equal in authority they're
not equal
in intelligence they're not equal in
maturity
well these days unfortunately i think
kids a lot of times are equal and
intelligent majority to their parents
that's part of
that's part of the problem here but they
shouldn't be
um you don't have to think of them as
inferior
you know if you don't want to put it
that way they are underdeveloped
in those areas whereas you are or should
be
more developed but what there is not is
equality
so kids are equality in this spiritual
moral worth
kind of sense that's a very important
sense but they're not equal in any other
way
what does not equal me it just means
different
these are different so you are different
from your child you're in a different
place in life
and that's why this the home cannot be a
democracy
this reading mama.com is a blog created
by a former classroom teacher and
reading tutor with a masters in reading
and a grad certificate in dyslexia and
language based learning differences
she was one of those people like many
who never thought they would homeschool
but god called her two at 11 years ago
because of some unique
learning challenges her oldest child had
she found herself entering the
homeschool world
it's been one of the best the most
challenging experiences of her life
there's nothing that compares to seeing
the light bulb come on
when your child gets a concept and you
know you taught it to them
because of her passion for teaching kids
especially struggling learners she began
creating and sharing resources for other
homeschooling parents
the goal of everything she creates is
twofold one to make learning fun and
engaging which is what it should be and
two to break
down difficult concepts so it's easier
for learners to grasp them over the past
10 years she's created thousands of free
printables on her blog from teaching
rhyming words to working on complex
comprehension skills
she has some free resources for other
subjects too like math and science
if you go to thisreadingmomma.com you
can find all the free printables by
clicking on
free printables at the top of her blog
you can also find her shop
there you'll find a reading curriculum
even more resources for struggling
learners
spelling games and her homeschool plan
check out her blog
and all the resources she has to offer
use coupon code walsh for 30
off uh off the products from her shop
um okay i can't take many more of these
we'll do uh
all right let's try this one
how inspiring how inspiring
another child prop here
even if it could be appropriate to have
your son
leave the house in a dress which it
isn't
see this is not a this is not a problem
for me as a father
i don't have to think about this one my
sons have never
asked to wear dresses if they did
i would have no problem saying no you
know what i would say
god forbid you know what i would say
this is how unenlightened i am i would
say can you believe it
i'd say to my son you're not wearing a
dress
boys don't wear dresses
but i really want to wear a dress but
you're not going to
that's what i would say and that would
be it that it would be over
my son's um theoretical gender
self-identity crisis would be over right
then and there
i just put an end to it and then we go
out and we we just live our lives and
everything will be fine
it really is that simple most of the
time but even if it could be
appropriate let's just say sake of
argument
to have your son leave the house in a
dress the fact that you're filming it
and putting it online proves that you
aren't doing this for him
it proves that you're you're you're
doing it for a reason has nothing to do
with his well-being
his welfare his development
you're doing it so that you can brag
about it
and that's why these parents these uh
parents that are raising gender diverse
kids or whatever the phrase is now
they always love talking about it
because it's all about them every time
are you know what let's look at one more
let's see if we can find
somewhere on tick tock some good
parenting
and maybe we'll find it here let's watch
[Music]
i mean it happens to the best of us i
cannot tell you how many times i've
accidentally drop kicked a baby while
pole dancing
it it you know it can really happen
anyone don't get the baby
kick the baby but really why are you
filming a pole dancing video
at all but when you have like a
six-month-old crawling around the house
who's watching that kid apparently
nobody
and then why did you post it i assume
i assume this wasn't live streaming so
she was trying to take a tick tock video
of herself pole dancing
for whatever reason and she accidentally
drop kicks her baby
in the face in the process and then
watches the video back
and says oh this is great stuff let's
put it on so everyone can see me doing
it
this is why when i see these videos at
least the ones giving advice
um and and i give this woman credit
she's not like she isn't advising
that we drop kick our babies it's just
that she ha that's what she does
you know that's her own style um but
when i see the advice ones it only
solidifies my belief
that you should have to state your
credentials before giving parenting
advice
and i don't believe in this kind of
credentialism thing
in most situations but for parenting
there should be a law in place and if i
was in charge there would be a law
that you have to say at a minimum how
many kids you have
and how long you've been a parent and
whether any of your kids are currently
in prison
before you give any advice at all i'm
eight years in four kids and i'm barely
qualified to give advice
i'm only qualified at most to point out
the bad advice when i see it
and this is all bad advice so don't
listen to it
also don't listen to me don't listen to
anyone
you're on your own and alone
have a great day